troisième volet de notre de notre série
consacrée cette semaine à la santé ce
soir on s'intéresse aux frites des cours
de sport dispensés gratuitement par des
coachs dans des lieux publics un bon
plan surtout en cette période
d'inflation à Tours le concept fait de
plus en plus d'adeptes Faustine Nuno
s'est greffé à une séance d'abdos en
plein air regardez
3 2 1 allez on redescend petite pause on
va continuer avec les fessiers squatte
pompe abdos fessiers ont su déjà à
grosses goutte sur la place du bois à
Tours Nord alors c'est dur un peu oui
quand même c'est un peu physique ouais
j'en peux plus sur tout le cardio voilà
puis là on va devoir enchaîner donc
enchaîner les exercices pendant une
heure le tout dans la bonne humeur et en
extérieur c'est ce que propose
gratuitement l'association free fit
concept trois fois par semaine des
séances animées par des bén évoles
passionnés de sport comme Fred et Cédric
dans le rôle des coachs ça fait 6 mois
que j'ai intégré l'association j'ai été
participant pendant quatre ans et
maintenant m'a donné la chance
l'occasion de d'être coach donc je suis
accompagné par Fred et après ça permet
de qu'on puisse préparer des exercices
chez soi et après il y a plein de plein
de tutoriels etc et ça permet de de ben
justement de retransmettre ça à des gens
sportifs ou pas sportifs tout simplement
quoi
comme ça alors
coach ou plutôt faiseur d'ambiance
aujourd'hui c'est cardio et renforcement
musculaire Fred et Cédric envoie la
musique volume à fond l'objectif le
bien-être sous toutes ses formes ce que
c'est bien pour la santé physique ou
pour la santé psychologie les deux de
toute façon avec un corps voilà qu'on
forme quoi c'est la base cette séance du
mercredi elle est juste après le travail
c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle afterwork
et du coup c'est vraiment pour se
défouler après la séance de boulot et
on le voit donc du coup on retrouve les
habitués des nouvelles personnes qui
arrivent des nouveaux arrivants qui vont
probablement revenir à repris c'est dur
mais après au bout de plusieurs séances
ça fait du bien une fois qu'on l'a vu on
se sentir de nous et ça
[Musique]
on a peur hyper gras après quoi on a pas
envie de d'avoir fait tout ça pour rien
rendez-vous le lundi place de Strasbourg
le mardi au lac de la Bergeonnerie et le
mercredi place Louvois
[Applaudissements]